let's go next to
uh well where are we going to go next
because we really have quite a situation
happening on the phone lines let's go to
grant from ohio grant welcome
thank you david
for taking my call my pleasure
hey i was uh and grant we we've you've
got to turn off those discord blings
you've got to do do not disturb turn off
notifications you know whatever it is
that needs to be done we got to do it
all right sorry no
um
well hey i was uh wondering
if there was any updates with the map
gates um
uh the criminal
investigation with possibly sex
trafficking i know it's been going on
for quite some time i just saw a story
this morning and i just didn't have time
to um
look at it in detail
it's a daily beast story from yesterday
actually which is called eight sources
say the feds are not done with matt
gates and these eight sources told the
daily beast that the investigation is
still very much alive and that matt
gates is not out of the woods that's
this article you know and that's the
eight sources that they have i don't
know any more than that but that's you
know 12 hours old at this point so i
think that's the newest info
yeah i just saw an nbc poll or it says
he's going to win his district again oh
of course
and i think it also said that district's
been read since
at least 30 years ago it's been a long
time it's oh he's absolutely going to
win yeah i know i i think
listen what we know is he's a horrible
person he may have committed crimes and
there's currently a very serious
investigation into that
yeah it's just kind of yeah kind of sad
um and then
another
i don't know if this would be a personal
and also um professional question do you
ever plan on writing any books
um about i don't know about anything or
politics yeah i'm sort of working on a
proposal now and i have so many things
going on that that it's tough to finish
it and move on to the next step but i am
in the middle of a proposal and as soon
as i have something to announce on a
book i will
all right well thank you so much for
taking my call my pleasure grant thank
you uh uh there is grant from ohio very
very respectful
in every way which we love